on the shores of the gods I do north of
the Isle of faces Rises a monument to
arrogance and cruelty Harrenhal for a
people who prided themselves on their
ships the iron men of old seized any
chance to leave them and carved out a
vast kingdom from the peaceful River
Lords the Empire reached its zenith
under king Harun hora called the black
by those he terrorized and by his own
men though they meant it proudly King
Harun enslaved the river lands to raise
the mightiest fortress Westeros had ever
seen a castle that could garrison a
million men with walls so vast that
winters would come and go and besieging
armies grow old and gray before the
castle fell five towers he ordered
reaching into the heavens like grasping
fingers a monstrosity which he forced
our people to build for their own
subjugation but the very day the slaves
laid the last stone Aegon Targaryen and
his sisters arrived in the south when
they arrived with a small army
Harun laughed and shut the gates
Harrenhal would have its first test and
an easy one at that it failed
Harrenhal could have withstood an
assault from all the armies and Westeros
combined but Haran learned that the
tallest and thickest walls meant little
to dragons for dragons fly with Herron
and his sons dead Harrenhal quickly
surrendered to Aegon house Tully then
raised the river Lords and rebellion
against the Iron Islands and where the
Aegon we flushed the iron men to the sea
we should have torn down the castle
stone by stone then but Harrenhal seems
such a magnificent prize that Aegon gave
it to one of his commanders whose line
then with it to extinction as would
every family to her
thereafter when many speak of harrenhal
the voices
drop to whispers about mad lady lawson
who were said to send a giant bat to
collect children for her crockpots and
to bathe and blood and serve feasts of
human flesh about the ghosts of black
heron and his sons who still walk the
castle at night all aflame of the
servants who went to bed in full health
and were found in the morning burnt to
ash mere stories to frighten wayward
children and excite young girls you may
say you would not be entirely wrong
Harrenhal is a price a nigh impregnable
castle with enough land and enough
income to make a man at a stroke one of
the greatest Lords in Westeros but he
would not be entirely right either say
by a King's grace Harrenhal became yours
now you must garrison it you must repair
it and maintain it even stretched to the
ends of your means you cannot fill and
manage the whole castle so you would
treat your household to four of the five
towers then three then two then only the
bottom thirds of those you closed the
whole of a hundred Hoth's and take your
meals in your rooms even then you can't
shake the feeling of desolation that
Harrenhal and its vastness is devouring
you in later years as you bury a
grandson or a great-grandson the last of
your line you will know it has
you